dude are are your kids moms friends at
all uh what I never like to generalize
because or they or are they at least
cordial friends like they don't like the
ones who it's like they I I'll leave
that up to them in the narratives in
which they share every no like everybody
is
like nurturing and loving and respectful
enough that they they understand what's
going on so nobody got any problems or
any negativity like we fly on a higher
frequency than that so like but I ain't
you know don't expect everybody to be
hanging out together but it's like
listen I'm just trying to figure because
I've seen a lot of these Cults or cult
Netflix documentaries recently the Canon
cult is the Canon Cults a thing you must
wear a turban and Vietnam
let's have at least one base to operate
against the circadian clock
um nah man I think it's it's just I mean
obviously I'm probably just more open
and honest about myself you are very
very transparent about it I think look
at look at you know everybody from the
Bob Marley's to the Muhammad Ali's to
the you know Quincy Joneses of the world
these all of these great men have are
fathers of many and right but I do think
what you did was you did it all at once
hey man the clock is ticking it felt
like it was so crazy because like we do
a national syndicated radio show every
day and
I couldn't talk about you on the show
because our biggest affiliate was a real
92.3 yeah Power 106. and I did they
literally tell you don't talk about it I
just you know shout out to Doc I ain't
[__] with dogs of course he is but we
were our kids was playing together when
we was competition so
um it would be crazy because me and
James would be like [__] Nick's having a
[__] we can't talk about it I felt like
every six weeks there was just a new I
think it's it's it's you know because
all the kids are going to be pretty soon
so this is going to be an interesting
upbringing I mean I'm pretty sure there
will be some challenge but I think
there'll be some beautiful things
graduation put them all in the same
school I'm hoping I mean in the same
area it all depends you know what I mean
but you know even some of my kids right
now are homeschooled so it's like we'll
we'll figure all of that stuff what will
school be in 10 years if you want to be
honest with it you know based off of the
way the world is going so I I think you
know a lot of my kids right now are
active in extracurricular activities and
sports and stuff so that probably we
might become challenging to where you
know they're definitely trying to make a
certain similar games on certain days
you know baseball basketball on track
overlap you know what I mean so even
sometimes they can't even make it to
their own games so it's like it's always
going to be something you've only been
married once so what's tomorrow yeah
yeah and it only will be married once
it's only going to happen so when all
this starts first happening right yeah
does Mariah call you be like what the
[__] are you doing bruh not really we
have that type of like type of
conversation but she's a little bit more
understanding she's going to be like
I'll see you out there Making Waves like
she kind of comes from it more from that
perspective but that there was no I
think only sometimes maybe when things
in the media get misconstrued or people
make up stuff like you got to clear it
up yeah we talk every day so I'm like yo
like it was some wild [__] of like
saying that we were having like a
custody battle or something I saw that
yeah and it's like I was like we just
was at dinner yesterday you ain't tell
me you know but it's like once we kind
of do away with all the rumors because
people do like to start rumors and
operate in that low frequency but we are
we all be on the same phase do you still
have the tattoo did you cover it up I
added to it shall we say cat
it's my whole that was my only tattoo at
one time now I remember I remember yeah
I was like this this guy's outside yeah
yeah yeah he got the home it was Mariah
Carey you damn right I can't buy or
nothing that she can't buy it Ryan Carey
was my as a small child she was like my
first crush yeah so when I saw I was
like shout out to Nick man it was Brian
JLo yeah and actually my boy ended up
being with JLo Casper Smart see look at
his young tycoons out here in these
streets getting it together man